[Música]
estas vacaciones me fui a barcelona con
mi mamá
un día quisimos ir a hacer un picnic en
un barrio
ella sabía estaba ahí entonces me dijo
bueno nos tomamos este subte hacemos
combinación acá y nos bajamos allá
no le entendí nada yo barcelona lo único
que conocía era messi entonces agarré
bull maps y me fijé algunas maneras de
cómo llegar
la primera opción que aparecía en un
bondi que tardaba la mitad del tiempo
entonces le dije mira ma
este va por un camino mucho más corto y
rápido
lo miro así como de reojo y me dijo no
no no vamos como dije yo
me quedé muy mal
y me sentí muy frustrado
no entendí qué pasó
y esta es la impotencia que siento cada
vez más seguido en los últimos años
de tener la respuesta para algunas cosas
pero no pueden usarla
y no porque no quiera sino porque no me
están dejando
mirémoslo así por un lado tengo un libre
acceso a la información
o sea que teniendo conexión internet
saco mi teléfono y pin bum bum
yo puedo saber cosas desde por ejemplo a
qué velocidad habría que pegar una
cachetada a un pollo para que se cocine
hasta cómo llegar a una plaza en una
ciudad desconocida
y no sólo eso yo no puedo no estar al
tanto las redes sociales no tienen un
celular porque tarde o temprano quedaría
desactualizado y afuera de todo
y por otro lado toda esta información
choca de frente
contra una pared enorme
los adultos
por ejemplo hace unos meses quise salir
a andar en bici por primera vez con mis
amigos
y mis papás no me dejaron
son muy chiquitos todavía no podés
chiquito para que qué cosa no sé
si se sabía andar en bici y se había
jubilado cómo ir y cómo volver
y acá es donde mi cabeza hace
porque entra como un loop
al tener acceso a tanta información me
siento presionado hasta incluso empujado
a entrar al mundo adulto
es como que me dijeran bueno campeón
como la escencia terminó
no tampoco vean el derecho a decidir
entonces es adolescencia que estaba por
terminar se termina haciendo eterna
ahora yo entiendo que me falta
experiencia
cuando mis papás no me dejaban salí
andar en bici
no les hice caso
y me fui con mis amigos
andando la bicisenda se nos cruzó un
perro sin correa
yo casi lo quiso
claro que jamás podría haber previsto
eso
pero creo que mi falta de experiencia no
justifica aún no poder porque esos
chicos como única respuesta
me parece que hay un problema nuevo en
la relación con los adultos
antes la información el derecho a
decidir estaban juntos de una misma
persona
ahora hay veces en las que yo tengo
tanta o hasta incluso más información
que ellos
y yo creo que esto debería darnos a los
jóvenes la oportunidad de ocupar un
lugar pequeño tenemos poder no más
libertad
la toma nuestras propias decisiones
algo tiene que cambiar
no sé cómo van a hacer estos cambios'
aunque hay buenas cosas que me dejan ver
más o menos por dónde va la cosa
por ejemplo cuando volvimos de las
olimpiadas de química mi profesora nos
propuso a tres compañeros ya mí de
ayudarla a estar en redes de la guía e
inventar nuevos ejercicios
pero además lo mejor de todo fue que en
la guía puso nuestros nombres junto al
de ella y profesor luís hecho antes una
cosa así
y en casa también me están empezando a
era un lugar distinto
mi papá que es abogado este año se
inscribió para la carrera de psicología
y tenía que reunir biología que digamos
que no es fuerte
ahora cuando se enteró de que a mí me
iba bien en esa materia
chau me dijo pibe
hasta que no sepa lo que es una
procariotas no salida acá
y ahora cada que nos saltamos quedar
juntos
siento que estoy con un compañero más
del colegio
yo estoy seguro de que el vínculo con
los adultos va a cambiar
dicen por qué
porque cuando fuimos a ese parque en
barcelona
fuimos a usted como dijo mi mamá
pero la vuelta
a la vuelta volvemos un molde
[Aplausos]
[Música]